you shut this film instant family mm-hmm
yeah and it's a comedy and this is just
feel-good comedy it's a it's a comedy
but it's you know I bet someone's gonna
cry but there's gonna be some tears yeah
heartfelt okay all right yeah you said
that in the least heartfelt way possible
heartfelt yes heartfelt did you learn
anything about the the business of being
in a movie by shooting this what did you
learn I mean I've been in movies before
but I mean I was the cast is incredible
it's you know Mark Wahlberg and Rose
Byrne I mean she was ridiculously
hilarious and then Octavia Spencer you
know I was a social worker with Octavia
and I don't know how I ended up in this
situation it was almost you know
infuriating that I got cast in this
movie with all these amazing actors but
I don't know how many professional
actors there are here tonight but when
you're filming a scene they have a mark
on the floor that they don't put in the
shot and then that's where you stop in
your scene and then you deliver your
lines and Octavia and I would walk up to
our marks and I'm so you know I consider
myself a comedian even though there are
long stretches where there's not a laugh
[Laughter]
and you know Octavia is she's won Oscar
and Oscar and and uh and so you know we
walk up to the are our marks and I'm
still nervous when I'm acting and I see
Octavia in a scene just kind of finish
her line and then move a little off from
her mark and do her own thing maybe add
a couple extra words it weren't there
and I'm just left at my mark just like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and it gave me confidence in another
scene what I you know going up to our
our marks and then when she walks off
I'm like I'm gonna I'm coming with the
Octavia to move off your mark and I
might have ruined the movie I don't know
but you're gonna be out of focus for
half the movie now it's gonna be a
close-up of my ear
you